I've been sent another
maximization or minimization
problem, and this seemed to be
an interesting twist on what
we've already done, so
let's do this one.
Let's see.
A rectangular storage container
with an open top is to have
a volume of 10 meters cubed.
The length of its base
is twice its width.
Let me start drawing
this thing.
It's a rectangular storage
container with an open top.
So let's see, let me do
it a different color.
OK, so I'll do it over here.
So that's its base.
So let's see.
The length of its base
is twice its width.
So this is the base, and if
I call this the width, so
this is x, the length is
twice that, this is 2x.
The length of its base is
twice the width, right?
So this is the length of the
base, this is the width.
OK?
Material and then the height,
for now, is unknown.
I think we should be able to
find a constraint on this,
because we know what the
volume has to be, right?
It says, materials for
the sides of cost $6
per square meter.
Find the cost of materials for
the cheapest such container.
OK, so let's do a
couple things.
First, let's figure out what
the height is in terms of x,
and then we can find an
equation for the cost in terms
of x, and then take the
derivatives, and find the
minimum, et cetera, et cetera.
So what do we know about this?
What's the volume of this box?
The volume of this box is
equal to the, what did I
say, this is the length, but
it doesn't really matter.
Length times the width
times the height.
So it's 2x times x,
2x squared times h.
So it's 2x squared
times h, right?
Base times height times
width, whatever.
Length times width
times height.
Just the volume of a rectangle.
And they already said that the
volume is 10 meters cubed,
so that gives us a
good constraint.
So that has to equal 10.
Let's divide both sides by 2x
squared, and so what do we get?
If we take this equation, we
divide both sides by 2x
squared, we get h is equal to
10 over 2x squared, which is
equal to, we could say,
5x to the minus 2 power.
So this is, so we could
write this as 5x to
the minus 2 power.
That is h.
We have just solved that.
We were able to solve that
because they gave us constraint
on the volume of the box.
Fair enough.
So now let's see what the cost
of the material, the total cost
of the material,
is going to be.
So I'll do that in magenta.
The cost of the material.
And I can even say,
as a function of x.
is equal to what?
OK.
Material for the sides
costs $6 per square meter.
So what is the surface
area of the sides?
Oh no, they tell the material
for the base first.
So material for the base
costs $10 per square meter.
So this base right here,
the material costs
$10 per square meter.
So what is the
cost of the base?
It's going to be area
of the base times 10.
So it's 10 times the
area of the base.
What's the area of the base?
It's 2x times x.
So it's 2x squared.
So this is the cost of the
material on the base.
And now we want to add the cost
of the material on the sides.
So.
And this is where gets a
little bit interesting.
So there's two sides that
are x, this side and this
side are the same size.
Right?
And so what are they?
What are their areas?
So it's going to be $6 per
square meter for those
two sides, right?
For this green side, and that
one back there, as well.
I don't want to make
this too messy.
So $6.
And what's the area?
And there's 2 of these
sides, I'm going to
multiply them by 2.
And so what's the area
of each of these sides?
It's x times 5x minus 2.
So that's 5x minus 1.
All right?
So now we have to figure
out this side here and
that side over there.
And let me do it in
a brown, maybe.
So now we care about this
side up in front, and then
that side back there.
But that's also going
to cost $6, right?
So plus $6 per square meter.
And then there's two sides,
and then what is it?
It's 2x times 5x to
the negative 2.
So that's 10, right, 2 times
5 is 10, x times, x to the
negative 2, x to
the negative 1.
Let's simplify this.
So we have the cost, and it
said it was an open top, so
there's no there's no fabric
we need for the top.
So the cost of putting the
fabric, or the material, on
this on this open rectangle,
is, see, 20x squared plus,
what's this, 12 times 5 is 60x
to the minus 1, plus, let's
see, 12 times 10, 120x to the
minus one, and so we can
further simplify that as 20 x
squared plus 180 x to
the minus 1 power.
And now we're ready to just
take the derivative and
find out what the minimum
point is of this curve.
So let's do that.
So c prime of x, and this is
a fun, non-hairy derivative.
So it's 40, 2 times 20
x and then minus 180
x to the minus 2.
And the minimum or maximum
point are going to be where
this is equal to 0, so
let's set that equal to 0.
Let me clear up some space.
I think you understand
all of this, so let
me get rid of that.
Actually, I like the drawing,
but it's got to go,
because I need the room.
If you need to review it,
just rewind the video.
OK.
So we want to set the
derivative, to find the minimum
or maximum point, at minimum or
maximum point on the curve, the
slope is 0, so the
derivative is 0.
So let's figure that out.
So 40x minus 180 x to the
minus 2 is equal to 0.
And the first thing I would do
is just, you could divide both
sides by 20, and you get 2x
minus 9x minus 2 is equal to
0 divided by 20, which is 0.
And then, let's
see what you get.
If you add 9x to the minus 2 to
both sides, you get 2x is equal
to 9x to the minus 2, or
9 over x squared, right?
That's the same thing
is 9x to the minus 2.
Now, I don't know, let's
multiply both sides of this
equation by x squared, so you
get 2x to the third is equal to
9, or x to the third is equal
to 9/2, or x is equal to the
cube root, or we could just
say 9/2 to the 1/3 power,
whatever that could be.
4.5 to the 1/3 power.
And do we know that this is a
minimum or a maximum point?
Well, we could go and take the
second derivative, and then
confirm that we're concave
upwards at this point, and then
we would know that we are at a
minimum point, and this is
the cheapest such container.
But I'll tell you a
little, you know.
If you see this in a class, or
maybe you want to prove that
for yourself on a test, but an
easy way to test that is just,
try some other x, right?
We have the cost
function right here.
Try some other x.
And you know that this is
either going to be a maximum or
a minimum, or at least a local
maximum or minimum, or if you
try another x and if it's
greater, then you
have a minimum.
Or the other thing is, well,
you know, if there's only one
critical point, and they ask
you to find the cheapest
container, that critical
point is probably going
to be the minimum point.
But anyway.
So just for fun, let's
figure out what that
is actually equal to.
I'll actually go to
google.com, and let's see.
We could just say, we want
9/2 to the 1/3 power.
So that is 4.5 to the 1
divided by third power.
1.65.
So that's our answer.
If x is equal to 1.65, you
know, plus some other points,
then we have the cheapest
container to produce.
It's 1.65 something something.
And there you have it.
Hopefully you found
that vaguely useful.